Yahoo Sports NBA senior writer Chris
Mannix take your victory lap Rubio had a
nice night victory is mine dan victory
is mine a sweet day in the morning
victory is mine you know
you know what I am Dan oh you're a lot
of things I am anything that's true but
I'm like Pythagoras back in like the
sixth century remember he declared the
world was round he was ridiculed back
then for all his views and he was right
back then I have been mocked for years
on this show nine years to be exact on
Ricky Rubio and I was proven right over
the weekend you're very very patient
you waited that long just to get your
moment your victory laughing you never
gave up this Rubio loved you as much as
you loved Rubio that's what I want to
know sadly despite my many attempts to
cultivate a friendship with Ricky Rubio
it has not we have not messed well I've
tried to do it individually I've tried
to do it through the Jazz PR department
I'm borderline stalking him it's not
good Wow but Russell Westbrook jr. the
third said that that's not going to
continue here you know Russ is gonna
play some defense with Rubio they're not
going to give him those those jumpers
there I think but that's really where is
that even though you cut me off you know
last time for the record Ricky Rubio
since late January has been one of the
best players in basketball look at his
numbers he's been great so this is not
an aberration this is not a one-game
thing Ricky Rubio is one of the biggest
reasons that Jazz are here right now up
to one the Thunder he's gonna play a
great game at Game four all right this
was the scene last time Mannix was on
when I cut him off Danny I just like the
opportunity though quickly bring to your
attention videos candidacy for Most
Improved Player let me give you two ten
seconds here so as you know we always
been arguing NBA's best player since the
all-star break his score has jumped some
teams the three-point shot obviously
believed to be an Achilles heel has
become a weapon for him
mm that's it I gave him 10 seconds I
give you a lot of time with Rubio here I
mean that was just plain rude like that
was that was you know what that's the
way Russell Westbrook's gonna treat
Rubio this next game the way I treated
you okay
okay even do you even like based on
everything you've seen from Westbrook
and this Thunder team this year do you
can you say with absolute confidence
that in Utah per game or that Russell
Westbrook can outplay Ricky Rubio oh no
I can't say with all certainty but if I
was gonna combine all of our stats
I'm gonna guess Russell Westbrook is
gonna have a better game than Ricky
Rubio
well here's the problem though when
Russell Westbrook tries to outplay one
individual player it oftentimes doesn't
go well for Oklahoma City in the numbers
I don't know what they are right now but
when you look at when Westbrook takes 17
shots or more or less Thunder win with
under 17 shots they tend to be right
around 500 or worse when he shoots over
17 so you know maybe Russell Westbrook
doing that Dan is exactly what Utah
wants let him go for 30 and 15 and 10 or
whatever it is but take 30 shots to get
there you talk about make that anybody
in trouble here like what you've seen so
far
you know Toronto you know crashing in
second halves Cleveland barely survives
heading back home Milwaukee in Boston
the 76ers though it looks like they'll
move on Spurs got a win but Golden State
will move on Rockets Tim wolfs so anyway
I mean any surprises
well Toronto just folding after you know
a couple of games and owning Washington
was was I don't know if it was
surprising because they're a completely
different team when they play on the
road and we look at all their numbers
they call off a cliff when they play on
the road but I thought that winning that
game 1 which has been kind of an
Achilles heel for them over the years
that that would would give them some
momentum now they've got a hope they can
reclaim that magic going back to Toronto
I tell you Dan
Cleveland pulled his fat out of the fire
last night that that might have just won
them the series there
and I think Indiana's a resilient brunch
in every game you look at every game of
this series it's kind of gone according
to you know one weight it's Cleveland
building a big lead Indiana trying to
claw its way back twice it's worked
twice it hasn't but the Pacers their
decision to kind of play hero ball at
the end of that game to go for let you
know that three-point dagger with four
or five minutes left to go that cost
them and I wonder if we're looking back
at this game for and how they played in
that last five minutes as you know the
day that they lost this series I hope I
get a chance to talk to you after the
next game with Ricky Rubio and his
performance against Oklahoma City do I
get to call in like every time Ricky
Rubio goes for a triple-double do I get
yes are you like 5 minutes yes okay
Sammy I'll talk to you about five five
years bang on that feedin bang on that
thank you Chris
hang on what does that mean seaton bang
on that I don't know yeah Mannix kind of
Kirk Cousins off-shoot yeah I don't know
what that means
Chris Mannix Channel who sports an idea
that's true for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]